any lie that we have that's running us
it will become our personal law we can
we can change States we can change
relationships but that lie will run us
and it'll act as our personal law until
we neutralize it look within we see the
LIE we dismantle it through prayer
through meditation through forgiveness
until it's no longer operating within us
now we become free and we see life
differently we see people differently
but the possibilities can only come into
manifestation if the condition is right
you know you can have a you can have a
seed the seed has the potential to be
whatever if you're holding a seed
thought whether it's the sea thought is
affirmative or whether the seed thought
is not affirmative if you create the
condition
that thought will emerge what you're
looking for you're looking with you're
looking with that Dynamic so you're also
helping to create the condition for that